[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
for today's video we're going to be
jumping all the way back to three months
ago
when the hogwarts legacy trailer was
premiered if you didn't know already
hogwarts legacy is a new harry potter
game set to be released in 2021
while we've had plenty of harry potter
games in the past not many of them have
been particularly
successful this new game aims to break
that failure streak with a new format
an open-world single-player action
role-playing game
which will allow you to create your own
personal witch or wizard inspect them
exactly as you want them to be
players will experience life as a
student at hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry like never before
as they live the unwritten and embark on
a dangerous journey to uncover a hidden
truth of the wizarding world
they will grow their characters
abilities as they master powerful spells
hone combat skills and select companions
to help them face off
against deadly enemies players will also
encounter missions and scenarios
that will pose difficult choices and
determine what they stand for
in addition to approaching the game from
a new and different perspective
open world format the teams at portkey
games and avalanche software who are
working on the game
have expressed that the graphics and
interactivity will truly set the game
apart from former games
with innovative high definition graphics
a player can practically feel the terror
of inferi
bearing down upon them since the ground
rumbling beneath them as a herd of angry
centaurs surrounds them
even dueling against a deadly dark witch
takes on a new level of realism
thanks to the controller's ability to
imbue sound and touch into every moment
if you're anything like me the moment
you heard of this game your mind
probably wondered this
will i interact with any of the
characters that i know and love
will this be the same harry potter world
that i'm used to the answer to that is
well sort of it turns out the game will
actually take place around 100 years
before harry potter starts attending
hogwarts
you'll play as a student attending
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
during the late 1800s and just like any
other student at the hogwarts will
attend classes and learn magic
alongside your classmates you have
received a late acceptance to the
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
and soon discover that you are no
ordinary student you possess an unusual
ability to perceive
and master ancient magic even more
exciting it looks as though you'll be
able to somewhat determine your own path
good or evil while pursuing the game's
missions this
should certainly keep things interesting
and well more realistic
since the trailer was released on
september 16th very little information
has been released about the game
and in high anticipation fans have begun
making all sorts of speculations
we know one thing for sure the game
takes place 100 years before harry
begins attending the school
this opens up a lot of questions will
dumbledore be in the game
grindelwald will we see familiar faces
within the walls of hogwarts
but perhaps one of the biggest questions
is who is the main villain
like most games there simply must be a
primary antagonist
an enemy a bad guy given that the game
takes place in a time that far precedes
the traditional harry potter timeline
we should be able to rule out the
obvious choices voldemort wasn't born
until 1926
which means that he's decades too late
to be the villain for this game
and grindelwald was born in 1883 which
seems just a bit too late
for the late 1800s setting that game
creators have mentioned
so the question remains who is the
villain i've got a few theories
my first theory is that it was a dark
wizard by the name of acrysdis
i've mentioned the christus in my past
videos but in case you don't know about
him here's a recap
basically he's a dark wizard who's
talked to have created the dementors
very little is known about him other
than the fact that he was alive during
the 15th century
that he was evil oh and he was massively
powerful at performing dark magic
as well a christus isn't particularly
well known but he certainly marked his
place in wizarding history
as he was a practitioner of the worst
kinds of dark arts imaginable
no one even knows his nationality and
even if it was known
i'm sure no one would want to claim
ownership of him a christus was the
original inhabitant of the island
fortress of azkaban
what we now know as the prison that
holds some of the darkest witches and
wizards
within its walls while traveling in the
15th century the crystal stumbled upon
the island
which at the time had no infrastructure
to speak of
a crisis began to use the island for his
own personal dark arts experiments
luring mughal sailors to the island then
torturing and eventually murdering them
before ever stepping foot on the island
christus was mad
but after spending some time there he
became totally insane
as he had completely lost touch with
reality he became so wrapped up and
enthralled in his experimentation with
dark magic
that he had lost his mind in his madness
it has been
speculated that a crisis either
unwittingly or perhaps intentionally
created
what we now know to be dementors given
that witches and wizards can live for
hundreds of years and that no one
actually knows what happened to a
crisdus
i think he would make sense as an
antagonist for the game sure
there have been other dark wizards
throughout history but acrystus really
seems to fit the bill
as far as proximity and time frame are
concerned
he's been known to exist on the island
of azkaban which is not particularly far
from hogwarts
he's a massively powerful wizard so i'm
sure it would have been possible for him
to stay alive longer than average
he created the dementors which we know
to exist in the game
and i have speculated in a previous
video that he also created the inferi
which also happened to be in the game my
next theory is that it was in fact one
of the previous owners of the elder wand
the elder wand is the most powerful one
in existence and throughout history it
certainly fell into the wrong hands on
more than one occasion
with all sorts of dark wizards using it
for evil the wander would pass hands
quite frequently with one evil wizard
besting another every few decades
a few wizards come to mind that could
have possessed the wand during the
game's time period
the first wizard that comes to mind is
barnabas deveral a wizard who
in the early mid 18th century began
using the one for evil
earning himself quite the reputation it
has been expressed that barnabas reign
of terror only ended when he was finally
defeated by another wizard
though barnabas could potentially be the
antagonist i do think that he may have
existed a little bit too early
the next owner of the elder wand however
a man by the name of loxius
very well could be lock cs is the man
who famously gave the elder wand the
name
the death stick as with it he ruthlessly
murdered many people
throughout the wizarding world loxes
wasn't just a little bit twisted or a
little bit power hungry
he was a truly evil dark wizard but many
wanted dead
and according to dumbledore many claimed
to have been the one to finish him off
even his own mother because no one knew
who killed him
this point in history is a bit blurry
with regards to who became the next
owner of the elder wand
and this is why i think that loxes could
very well be the villain
the fact that no one actually knows who
killed him seems just so
convenient additionally it helps that we
know that
a he was a ruthless dark wizard b he
existed in the late 18th century
c he possessed the most powerful wand in
existence
and d he is even known to dumbledore
which means
life must have been significant perhaps
we the player
are going to be the ones to fill this
void in history and defeat the evil dark
wizard
loxius however there is also always the
possibility that there will be an
entirely new villain
altogether we know for a fact that the
game will follow the wizarding world
lore set out in the original harry
potter novels
as the game creators have confirmed this
we also know that we are definitely
going to see some familiar faces and
places however they have also expressed
the story for the game itself
is mostly original and was written by
the studio not by jk rowling
what this means is that we may just
encounter a dark wizard that we've never
seen before
what do you guys think who is the
villain going to be in hogwarts legacy
are you excited for the game let me know
in the comment section below
until next time you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you